[Musique]
scheer réunionnaise chez réunionnais ce
matin je prends la parole en compte tenu
de la situation sanitaire exceptionnelle
que traverse toute notre nation
bien sûr j'ai attendu que le président
de la république s'exprime avant de
m'adresser moi-même aux réunionnaises et
réunionnais
dès la semaine dernière j'ai demandé aux
services du département en lien avec les
autorités locales et en particulier la
rs de travailler à l'adaptation du
fonctionnement de nos services dans
l'intérêt de l'ensemble de la population
il est essentiel je dis bien il est
essentiel de tout faire pour endiguer la
propagation de l'épidémie en faisant
preuve de la plus grande solidarité
collective possible
mon devoir est d'assurer aux
réunionnaises et aux réunionnais qui
bénéficient des services du département
que notre collectivité reste et restera
toujours présente à leurs côtés pour ce
faire nous avons d'ores et déjà mis en
place des mesures nécessaires pour
protéger l'ensemble de nos agents tout
en garantissant aux publics les plus
fragiles une continuité de service je
vous annonce que les services seront
fermés au public à compter de ce jour 12
heures en vue bien sûr de répondre à la
nécessité de confinement qui a été
demandée par le chef de l'état
une organisation a été définie et mise
en place pour répondre aux missions
essentielles d'urgence des équipes
dédiées ont été constitués ainsi que des
numéros d'appel que je vous demande
d'utiliser et surtout amusez-vous
mesdames et messieurs les journalistes
de relayer vers la population je pense
aux gramounes je pense aux enfants
je pense aux personnes en situation de
handicap
je pense au personnel médical et médico
social je pense au bon pied je salue je
les saluer
je connais leur dévouement je pense aux
assistantes familiales aux enfants
relevant de nos services je pense aux
indépendants nos agriculteurs au chef de
l'état au chef d'entreprise je pense à
toutes les réunionnaises et à tous les
réunionnais plus que jamais nous tout ne
doit être solidaire ne doit être
ensemble dans ce combat je sais que nous
pouvons travailler et rester solide et
nous devons bousculer nos habitudes nous
devons le faire quand tout
l'accompagnement possible de la force
publique ne pourra pas seuls 27 maladie
c'est le sens de la solidarité
réunionnaise que nous devons élever par
des gestes tout simples une nouvelle
case et si nous doit déplacer faut
respecter une certaine distance avec
chacun de nos voisins respecter les
gestes barrière au coeur de chaque
réunionnais nous savons tous la famille
est ce qu'il ya de plus sacré nos
gramounes sont nos piliers pour protéger
les fondations de notre société nous
devons malgré tout et sur un temps qui
doit être le plus court possible
s'assurer qu'il ne manque de rien tout
en évitant bien sûr de les exposer à la
maladie permettez moi de vous adresser
mes pensées les plus chaleureuses
ensemble agissons de façon unie
responsable et solidaire et c'est
ensemble que nous
vaincre cette maladie pas des gestes
tout simples des gestes citoyens tels
que de temps en temps régulièrement pas
mal à se frotter les mains avec du gel
donc le produit protecteur de nos mains
et bien faisons des gestes simples dans
cette existence d geste citoyen ou une
fois doit permettre de protéger nos
concitoyens nos voisins nos enfants nos
gramounes
[Musique]